Steven Miller former senior advisor and
president uh president Trump and founder
of America Le first legal the doj Steven
is threatening to sue Texas but not main
for disenfranchising voters the Biden
Administration uh I think they're trying
to show how serious they are about
immigration by visiting Mexico but then
they hamstring Texas but I don't think
they realize what a crisis Texas is
facing every
day
well they are very serious about
immigration they're serious about
maximizing the number of illegal
immigrants who enter the country every
single day every single week every
single month as you mentioned we just
saw in December the highest number of
illegal aliens illegal aliens in
American history nearly 300,000 this
comes after many previous record setting
months and at the same time we have
record low ice deportation so record
numbers coming across record few being
removed illegal aliens being recited in
Mass across the country and the state of
Texas stepping up trying to defend its
citizens defend its homes and property
is of course being sued by the
Department of Justice for not joining in
Biden's conspiracy to let many illegal
aliens limited unlimited numbers of
illegal aliens settle themselves all
across Texas and throughout America yeah
and the backlog on these cases is
unbelievable what is it 5 million people
it's something absurd the the backlog on
this thing 6 month migrant buses million
is it that high yeah six migrant buses
arrived today in New York City despite
mayor Adams's executive order and this
morning on CNN he said this about the
order watch with that executive order
was saying that between a certain period
of time you allowed to drop off uh
migrants in the city but you're going to
do it at the location that we specify so
we don't overtax our resources our
Manpower and create a disorderly
environment well they're still coming
and the fact is after his executive
order six more buses showed up does this
put any additional pressure on Biden as
we move into 2024 with so many
Democratic Mayors feeling the pinch and
and watching their City budgets be
destroyed only if republicans in
Congress get sophisticated and
determined very quickly The Chronic
underreaction to the worst illegal
immigration and the worst border crisis
in the history of civilization nothing
comes close nothing even approaches it
The Chronic underreaction is the biggest
impediment to stopping the Biden
sponsored border Invasion the house
should come back in January and vote on
immigration every day and every night
and nothing else issue by issue criminal
removals Catch and Release Sanctuary
City ities shutting down the Department
of Justice attack on the state of Texas
shutting down the secret night flights
shutting down the buses shutting down
the funding shutting down the funding to
the NOS shutting down every single
element of this crisis restoring remain
in Mexico restoring safe third
agreements restoring prosecutions of
criminal entry restoring title 42 every
day every hour if that's what it takes
it's not enough to say oh we voted on a
board security Bill a year ago
congratulations a year ago you voted on
a board security Bill I'm need the house
to get in the game every single day
because every single day we are losing
this country to a degree of illegal
immigration that no civilization could
possibly endure it is impacting every
community in the world and certainly in
our country every Community including
New York City Stephen thank you so much
for being here hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else